ينضم الينا من غلاف غزه مراسل الجزيره
الياس كرام الياس نبدا
للحشود العسكريه الاسرائيليه في منطقه
الغلاف بحسب ما تقول بيانات المقاومه ال
الفلسطينيه وراينا ذلك ايضا في الايام
الماضيه في خضم المعارك التي تشهدها
المناطق الشماليه والمناطق الوسطى لقطاع
غزه حيث ان المقاومه الفلسطينيه كانت سددت
كثير من هذه الضربات الصاروخيه باتجاه
البلدات الاسرائيليه في غلاف غزه والسلاح
الجو الاسرائيلي قبل قليل اغار على منطقه
جحر الديك هذه المنطقه الواقع قع الى
الجنوب من مدينه غزه وهي الان تشهد كما
نستطيع ان نسمع من هنا من منطقه الغلاف
اشتباكات مسلحه ما بين القوات الاسرائيليه
والمقاومه الفلسطينيه بمعنى ان المعارك ما
زالت مستمره ما زالت ضاريه ما زالت تسري
في كل المناطق في شمال ووسط قطاع غزه رغم
كل الغارات الجويه ورغم كل القصف المدفعي
الذي استمر طيله الساعات الماضيه اي ربما
بكثافه متفاوته بين الحين والاخر احيانا
يشتد احيانا يخف لكنه لا يتوقف البته
التركيز من ناحيه القوات الاسرائيليه
المتمركزه في غلاف غزه كان هذا الصباح
ايضا على الضواحي الشماليه لمدينه غزه
التي تعرضت لقصف مدفعي شديد وغارات جويه
ايضا تحديدا حيي الدرج والتفاح حيث يقول
الجيش الاسرائيلي بانه
بدا عمليه عسكريه هناك منذ اكثر من ثلاثه
ايام لكن ايضا المناطق الشماليه في اقصى
شمال قطاع غزه كجمال المخيم وجماليا البلد
وبيت حنون وبيت لهيه كلها مناطق ما زالت
تتعرض للقصف المدفعي وللقصر الجوي ايضا
مخيمات البريج
والصراط كانت في الساعات الاخيره عرضه
لغارات جويه عنيفه ولقصر مدفعي شديد وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي ي اف جلان قال بان جل
العمليات العسكريه وتركيزها الان هو في
منطقه خان يونس حيث تنشط الفرقه ال8 في
الجيش الاسرائيلي ومن تحتها سبعه الويه
تابعه للجيش الاسرائيلي باسناد من
المدفعيه باسناد من سلاح الجوي الاسرائيلي
باسناد من كتائب اي وحده الهندسه ووحده
المدرعات وهذا يعني باننا نتحدث عن قوات
عسكريه قوامها على الاقل فرقتين في الجيش
الاسرائيلي وهذا يعني ان اعداد كبيره يعني
الاف الجنود الاسرائيليين يشاركون في
العمليه العسكريه في منطقه خانيونس وهذا
يعني ان الجيش الاسرائيلي يحاول ان يشكل
ضغطا عسكريا كبيرا على تلك المنطقه التي
يعتقد بانه يوجد فيها كبار القاده
السياسيين
والعسكريين التابعين لحركه حماس الجيش
الاسرائيلي يقول بانه يعمل فوق الارض
وتحتها بمعنى انه يعمل في انفاق المقاومه
الفلسطينيه الاستراتيجيه لكنه يعمل ايضا
هناك فدى بحذر شديد على اعتبار ان
المعلومات الاستخباراتيه لدى الجيش
الاسرائيلي تفيد ان معظم الاسرى
الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في داخل قطاع غزه
قد يكونوا موجودين في هذه الانفاق التي
يعمل فيها الجيش الاسرائيلي والتي يعتقد
بان كبار القاده العسكريين والسياسيين
التابعين لحركه حماس موجودين فيها لكن مع
ذلك فدى احتياج الجيش الاسرائيلي للواء
سابع والزج به الى المعركه وكما اشرت نحن
نتحدث عن قوه عسكريه قوامها فرقتين في
الجيش الاسرائيلي وهذا عدد كبير من ال من
الجنود هذا يعني بان الجيش الاسرائيلي في
مازق هناك وانه يواجه مقاومه شرسه وقويه
من جانب المقاومه الفلسطينيه مما يستدعي
الجيش الاسرائيلي الى استدعاء لواء سابع
والى استدعاء كل هذه القوات العسكريه
للمشاركه في هذه العمليه العسكريه الكبيره
لكن رغم ان الجيش الاسرائيلي كان يمن
النفس على ان ينهي عمليته العسكريه مطلع
هذا الشهر في المناطق الشماليه لكن كما
اشرت المناطق الشماليه ما زالت تشهد قصفا
مدفعيا عنيفا وغارات جويه عنيفه هنالك
اشتباكات مستمره طيله الوقت وبالتالي واضح
بان الانفاق الهجوميه ما ما زالت تستخدم
من جانب المقاومه الفلسطينيه لتسديد ضربات
لقوات الجيش الاسرائيلي وما زالت هذه هي
الوسيله ربما الاقوى بيد المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في مواجهه قوات الجيش
الاسرائيلي وهنالك من يعتقد ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي اصبح الان عالقا في داخل قطاع
غزه في حرب مدن دون ان يتمكن من احراز
صوره انتصار واحده وبالتالي هنالك من يحذر
من ان ال الجيش الاسرائيلي ربما بات يغوص
في وحل غزه وبات امام حرب استنزاف مع
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في كل محاور القتال
لذلك نحن نسمع بان الجيش الاسرائيلي بدا
يدعو المستوى السياسي لاتخاذ قرارات
سياسيه تتعلق في المرحله الثالثه التي بدا
يتحدث عنها الجيش الاسرائيلي والتي تتمثل
فد باعاده انتشار القوات الاسرائيليه ليس
انسحاب القوات لكن اعاده انتشارها وتموضع
في شمال ووسط قطاع غزه في اماكنه في محاور
قتال معينه في محاور اشتباك معينه
والانطلاق في المرحله الثالثه التي يقول
الجيش الاسرائيلي ويقول ايضا وزير الدفاع
يوف جلنت بانها سوف تستمر شهورا كثيره و
وهي تتمثل في عمليات الاغاره المحدوده
القيام بعمليات كوماندوز محدوده في داخل
قطاع غزه ضد اهداف بعينها تابعه لحركه
حماس او تابعه لباقي الفصائل الفلسطينيه
المقاول ولكن الجيش الاسرائيلي لا يبدو
انه قادر على الاستمرار في الهجوم على
النحو الذي نراه الان بمعنى الاشتباك من
مسافه صفر مع المقاومه الفلسطينيه
العمليات العسكريه التي يخوضها في المناطق
الماهوله وواضح بان الجيش الاسرائيلي يسعى
سريعا الى الانتقال الى المرحله الثالثه
وهذا ربما ما سياتي ايضا وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي في زيارته الخامسه الاسبوع
المقبل ليتحدث بشانه مع كبار القاده
السياسيين والعسكريين في اسرائيل ربما
الوقوف على الجدول الزمني لدى اسرائيل
للانتقال الى هذه المرحله التي نتحدث عنها
شكرا لك الياس كرام مراس الجزيره كنت معنا
من غلاف
غزه